copper prices are up and that means it's
been a bumper year for the footsie 100
mining giant Antofagasta and its
shareholders while copper prices were up
by 27 percent over the course of 2017
and that meant that revenues jumped by
23% to 4.7 billion dollars and fully a
pre-tax profit surged by 84% to 1.8
billion dollars all that is good news
for shareholders who'll enjoy 177
percent rise in the dividend well with
me now is Antofagasta seif executive eve
an area guard Eve I'm very good to see
so great run on the copper price last
year what are you expecting this year I
think we expect the the outlook for the
copper price to be a good for 2018 we've
seen strong growth in demand in China
that has sort of kept its space then
there is synchronized growth globally as
well and and there's also more demand
coming out of the you know clean economy
or clean transport and clean energy so
all of that reads well for the outlook
of copper so we expect you know that
we're going into a face in which copper
which we call a Tier one commodity we'll
have a good run what about costs what
are you seeing on that side of the
ledger we are seeing some some pressures
and cost out of input price increases
and also as exchange rate in most
producing countries strengthened but
we're working very hard to compensate
for those cost increases in the case of
Antofagasta we had our cost program
which achieved significant savings in
the course of last year around 160
hundred and seventy million dollars
which allowed us to compensate almost
two-thirds of the cost increases or
pressures that we saw coming from the
outside what about labor market now most
workers at your biggest mine loss
parameters have just voted to go on
strike presumably you are having to pay
the workers more right now well we have
a good track record in terms of Labor
Relations in Antofagasta we've actually
closed most of the negotiations with all
in all our sites last year and what has
happened now we've got one union left at
the lambdas which were negotiating the
contract with we submitted a contract
and they voted against and now we're in
the process of mediation so we continue
the dialogue and we expect a you know an
outcome which will satisfy satisfies
both sides you know in the next couple
of weeks so that's the process
were going through and without
pre-empting well the outcome might be we
want to strike a fair outcome combined
with preserving you know the
sustainability of the business in the
long term which means retaining the
competitiveness of our costs one of the
most interesting things about your
results is you more or less you what
wiped out your debts now of course in
the last big commodity supercycle all of
the mining companies racked up big debts
do you feel under pressure to start
gearing up again not at all I think
intifada has been the financial strength
that Antofagasta has been a key feature
in the past you know we've kept that
strength over the cycle and and in 2017
our operating cash flow was up
significantly we managed to continue D
gearing our balance sheet which is
almost without any debt in net terms and
combined with that you know to pay a
good dividend and return cash to our
shareholders so I think we are in a good
position we we want to focus on growth
going forward but growth which is return
focus which contributes and generate
value and we've got some Brown field
getting options for that purpose ativan
are a go are we gonna leave it there I'm
afraid thanks for joining me